[Music]
in the multiple movie universes of giant
monsters there are certain creatures
that live up to their name and even
fewer that become Legends and the way a
legend is born or made is through
martyrdom or death so will Godzilla die
in either the new minus one movie that
is said to be released this November or
in the upcoming gods exone the new
Empire that is slated for next year's
April looking at both these two movie
premises there is a strong chance that
we might witness the death of Godzilla
in either one of them or in the worst
case scenario his death in both Flakes
and if so in what way will Godzilla go
down and sleep with the
fishes so the impending release of minus
one is adding an air of mystery leaving
fans on the edge of their seats
wondering if this will be a movie that
sees the mighty Kaiju meet his and just
like how he did in the first ever movie
why Would Godzilla die you may ask
that's because in Godzilla minus one
Godzilla will be a malevolent force of
Nature and his main enemy is Humanity so
it's either us or the giant Kaiju the
movie minus one is also a reboot of the
first ever Godzilla movie of 1954 where
he dies due to a weapon called the
oxygen Destroyer so in this remake his
ultimate fate might follow what happened
in the first movie so as to be true to
the source material
however the suspense doesn't end there
for the Horizon promises another
colossal showdown in Godzilla xcong the
new Empire which will be seen this April
hopefully if there are no more delays or
strikes the clash between Godzilla and
Kong and GVK has already left a dent a
sense of Doom a grim mark on the
monsterverse and with the premise
suggesting a new era the question looms
larger than ever will Godzilla the
benevolent protector meet his demise in
the Epic confrontation against
formidable adversaries like scar and
shimu the notion that Godzilla might
meet his end in one of both films
injects an unparalleled sense of gravity
into the narrative prompting fans to
reflect on the consequences of such a
turn of events and what would they have
or bear on the monsterverse but I admit
it is less so for the Toho movie which
uh the company and its movies has had
its share of GDs or Godzilla Debs so now
the question is how will Godzilla die in
either movie and whether this is even a
possibility so let's start with the
monster verse first Monarch categorizes
Godzilla as a protector and a guardian
of the world while initially perceived
as a threat Godzilla has transformed
into a defender of the planet he is
territorial intervening to restore
equilibrium where it is Disturbed his
behavior displays minimal interest in
humans and directing his Focus towards
more of confronting the Rogue tians and
eliminating potential threats Godzilla
only engages with humans when they post
a risk of Awakening ing catastrophic
forces or harming other Titans whether
it's tthing the Awakening of Monster
Zero or trying to prevent the creation
of Mecha Godzilla or releasing the
captured Naka since humans in the most
of us have already used the oxygen
Destroyer against him and it failed its
Mark and they have also unsuccessfully
used up the Mecha Godzilla plot point
there is no way that if Godzilla is
killed in future movies it will be in
the hands of humanity furthermore the
controlling forces and the organization
of Monarch has declared Tanis Gojira as
sort of an ally of sorts or at the very
least a benevolent protector so killing
the Gman would be sort of an anti-
Common Sense thing the movie will fail
to gain an audience Godzilla will also
not die like the Jay version in a
catastrophic meltdown why because that
plot Point as well has also been used in
kotm where they stated that he was going
to explode and melt from the excessive
radiation given to him by S zawa but as
we all know it actually fueled the
multiple nuclear pulses that destroyed
the three-headed monster Monster Zero so
in the course of three movies Godzilla
has had his brush in with death a couple
of times and does as wise men say third
times the charm therefore will Godzilla
be killed by a Titan then well that's
the only viable pathway nothing else can
harm him except other Alpha Titans or
rope ones like Tiamat or Muto Prime with
the theory surrounding Scar and shimu
that will be seen in this new movie we
might just have to bring in tissues as
well to the big screens firstly scar is
stated to be a rival and a grave enemy
of Godzilla that had been defeated in
the past while shimu is theorized to be
the primogenitor of all tirant and
therefore a father to the super species
making him more powerful than any other
monster we have seen so far secondly the
moners with its movies is now
overextending a viable timeline and the
Mystery regarding giant monsters
therefore it is rightfully so that we
should not milk a cow till its dead and
lastly as we have stated it in the
beginning the only way a legend is born
is through the character's demise but
it's not to say that there won't be
another Godzilla or a Godzilla junior or
another Titan taking the mantle of
protector in the monster wore someone
like Kong for
instance so then regarding Godzilla
minus one the other movie that will be
seen this November or December depending
where you're from this is more of a
straightforward theme and it's not like
the monster ver where there can be a
long debate as to why Godzilla should
die or live here it is either one of two
endings either Godzilla dies due to a
secret weapon created by Japan more
specifically the oxygen Destroyer or a
version of it or he is driven back to
the ocean only to reappear in a sequel
and since there is no confirmed
Cinematic Universe for this Godzilla
which is basically planned to be a
standalone movie therefore there has to
be an ending and not a Cliff Hanger so
we will most definitely see Godzilla
minus one wreak havoc over Japan and the
ocean the Navy the US Military and also
be seemingly Invincible But ultimately
will meet his demise and the hands of a
few dedicated individuals trying to
protect Humanity this movie will present
Godzilla's death not only as a defeat of
the monster but also as a reflection on
the devastating power of nuclear weapons
and the sacrifices required to protect
the world so those are our theories on
whether Godzilla will die in minus one
or g escade a new Empire anyway with
that we come to to the end of this video
do like and share and subscribe and I
hope you have enjoyed watching it but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam